last week we were discussing
visiting the graves and
the way that a person should visit the
graves
we were discussing the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam with
[Silence]
foreign
we mentioned some of the etiquettes of
visiting the grave and how a person
should
visit the graveyards we mentioned that
when a person visits the grave
he should not walk over the graves he
should not stand on a grave he should
not sit on a grave
and some of the said of some of the
companions
and it's also been narrated in a
narration of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
that they would take their shoes off
when they would go into the cemetery and
walk between the graves
now this is something which is
preferable it's not something which is
absolutely mandatory and sometimes the
way that the graveyard is set up or the
amount of
people or the situation at hand may
cause a person to have to walk over a
grave
or to stand on a grave in this case
it would not be haram but to optionally
walk over a grave or to optionally stand
or sit on a grave this is something
which is
inappropriate and impermissible
likewise the issue of timing when a
person goes to visit the graves
there is a an innovation that is very
widespread
where people will go to visit the graves
on eid
day or they will go to visit the graves
on jummah
right and this is not something that the
companions or the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam used to ever do
there's no particular time or place when
a person should visit the great no
particular time
or occasion when a person should go
to visit the graves they visit the grave
when they have time
whether it's during a holiday whether
it's during jumaau whether it's during
on a monday or tuesday or just a regular
day on your way home from work
any time a person decides to go visit
the graves
but to go visit the grave on on a
day specifically or on juma's
specifically
every time or only to go during that
time
this is something that the scholars of
islam have mentioned is a type of
innovation
and this stems really from a belief
that the people in the grave can hear
the people who come to visit them
and this is incorrect
[Silence]
foreign
so we have narrations that mention
that the person in his grave hears the
person that comes to visit him
we have narrations that mention that
when a person goes to visit someone in a
grave
that the person in that grave is
comforted by the visitation
of the person and the correct opinion
is that the person who is in the grave
is unable to communicate or hear
those who go to visit them
and this is something which is clear in
the quran allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
in numerous verses and you are unable to
make the dead hear
he said sallallahu alaihi and he also
said to him subhanahu ta'ala
and you are unable to make those
in their graves here and he's also
mentioned
subhanahu ta'ala that the people
in the graves who are called upon by
their worshipers they cannot hear them
and if they could hear them they would
not be able to answer their calls
anyways these narrations
that mention that a person in his grave
can hear
they are two types there are narrations
which are
explicit they explicitly state this
but they are not authentic they are not
authentic narrations
and then there are other narrations
which are authentic
but they are not explicit what does that
mean
so let's take for example a narration
that most of us know
that is authentic the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
that when a person is placed in his
grave
allah subhanahu restores his hearing
and he is able to hear those who
who buried him leave the graveyard and
walk away
we've heard this an erasion many of us
know this narration
this doesn't mean that the person in his
grave hears
all the time it just means that this
particular occasion
at this moment they are able to hear
we can't take this and extrapolate from
it that
the person in his grave hears all the
time
we can't do that another narration which
is similar to this one
is in the battle of buddha when the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam addressed the
disbelievers who were killed and thrown
in the well
at the battle of badr and he called out
to them
and said
did you all find what your lord had
promised to be a true
or not and
are why are you speaking to bodies that
have
become you know that have begun to
decompose
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said to omar
lady nfc s
i swear by allah you are not able to
hear me any better than they are
right except that they are unable to
respond
now does this mean that all dead people
hear
in the way that these people heard no
that is not true
even they mentioned
regarding this narration that allah wa
ta'ala
a one-time thing
allowed these men to hear the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam
under those circumstances to increase
their anguish and to
greaten his victory sallallahu alaihi
wasallam over them
this is not something that happens to
everyone not all dead people can hear
if this were the case then the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would have spoken to
many graves and many dead people
much more than we have in narrations
right
he would have gone to the graveyard and
actually spoken
we would have lots of narrations where
he goes to the graveyard and speaks to
different
people of his companions but we don't
have that
all we have are isolated incidents and
we cannot take these isolated incidents
and extrapolate them to come with an
overall
theme and the reason for that is that we
cannot make ps on something that is part
of the unseen
[Arabic recitation]
people go to visit the graveyard during
aid they go to visit the graveyard
during jumaan they go to visit the
graveyard during these times
why do they do this often times it is
because of a belief
that the people in the grave can
actually hear them
and there are no authentic narrations
that
articulate that a person in the grave
can hear them
and this belief is actually very
dangerous
this belief is actually very dangerous
[Silence]
therefore it is conclusive
and it is the correct opinion that the
people in the grave cannot
hear they are unable to hear they are
unable to interact with this world
and there's something important where do
most of these
things come from where
people believe in hauntings
people believe in haunted houses haunted
places
haunted cemeteries right it's because
they believe that the dead can still you
know subhanallah the dead have nothing
better to do
than to hang out in houses and scare
people and run around
as if yani they are not tied up in a
much more important issue and that is
either paying or reaping the rewards of
their sins or good deeds
this is something very important for the
muslim to understand
this is not something that is a belief
of the muslim
allah
moving on to how the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would console
the people who passed away he said what
kanam
[Silence]
now we are speaking about how the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
do what is called
is a taser which is to console somebody
right to convey
a person's best regards to someone
who has
been bereaved right
obviously we have wakes that we attend
okay this is all part of the azap
process
he says it is of the heady
the way of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam that he was all
would always console and convey his
condolences
to the to the
family of the departed of the deceased
and it was not of his sunna that he
would gather
for that or that he would recite any
part of the quran during such gatherings
he would neither recite the quran at the
graveyard
nor anywhere else outside of the
and all of these actions that people do
he says is an innovation which is newly
invented
and something which is disliked this is
the words of ibn al-qaeda
so what he's speaking about is a
specific type of wake where people
get together they'll get together on the
third night or the seventh night or the
40th night
right and they will recite the quran or
sometimes in
other countries egypt and some of
these places they'll pay someone
and he makes all of his money that way
by reading the quran on behalf of
someone who died
so someone dies and they will go to the
sheikh
and they'll pay him money and the sheikh
will recite the mushaf on behalf of
the deceased and then they'll have an
anniversary every year on that time
they will gather all together and he
will recite the quran for them etc
all of this is innovation none of this
happened in the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
ever it never happened right
it never happened that the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam would recite
the quran on behalf of the dead
ever neither
nor any other part of the quran let
alone the entirety of the quran
this is something which is an innovation
and a newly invented matter we don't
find this in the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
we don't find this in the sunnah of the
companions
likewise
[Silence]
is
foreign
[Silence]
likewise we have this issue of 40 days
40 days comes up in a lot of cultures
right
in the asian cultures
in places pakistan india
places philistine places like
some of the slavic countries
that 40 days is the time of mourning
so if somebody dies we mourn for 40 days
what that entails differs based on the
country
and philistine which is a country i
lived in that i can speak about
we would not use the television
for 40 days we you know men would not
shave for 40 days
women would not go out for 40 days
etc
this number 40 days of mourning
this is something which has nothing to
do with islam
at all it's not taken from the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam or his
companions
it's not mentioned in the quran it's not
mentioned in the sunnah
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
this was not observed even for his death
[Silence]
this was not observed not even for his
death sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and when we trace back
these 40 days we find that this is
actually
been taken from the
hindu tradition the hindu tradition
they have mourning for 40 days the
hindus do a lot of weird stuff
and some of the things that they do is
that they
mourned for 40 days they have
anniversaries for death they
the woman if it's a woman her husband
dies this is considered a bad omen
she is her head is shaved
and she or she is placed in the house of
her
late husband and burned alive in that
house
they do all kinds of weird funky wonky
stuff and
some of the time these things are
these things are brought into islam
by muslims being affected by that land
or region
so if you want to if you want to trace
back innovation
okay you can always trace innovation
where it comes from
one of these innovations is this 40 days
where does it come from well
for example we have people that live
as a muslim minority amongst the
majority of hindus let's say
right and all of their neighbors and
everything that they grew up around and
everything that they know is that 40
days
is the thing so muslims start to do this
too
right and then when those muslims travel
outside of that place they spread that
belief
to other places when they go to
heads when they move to other
countries etc
right and over years over
you know decades or hundreds of years
centuries it starts to ingrain itself
deeper into muslim countries and muslim
communities to the point where it seems
it's part of islam but it has
nothing to do with islam
now if we look at for example
the worship of graves
if we look at the worship of graves
branches back and at the heart
of it is the belief that the person in
the grave can hear you
so people start to go to the grave
and make dua to the person in the grave
right and they start to make offerings
to the person in the grave
because the idea is the person in the
grave
is closer to a love than me
so if i'm nice to the person in the
grave he'll put in a good word with me
he'll put in a good word for me with
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
exactly what catholicism is based on
catholics that's exactly what they
believe
they worship mary they worship mary more
than they worship
jesus that they believe is the son of
god more than they worship god
right why is that because mary
she you know she has good she's she has
a good relationship with her son
you know so if i'm nice to the mother
right then the son
will put in a good word for me and then
he'll put in a good word
for me with his father right that's the
idea
this is this is this is exactly what
the mushrikeen believes
and so some of these beliefs are
extremely dangerous
and it's important that we understand
the danger of these beliefs
likewise we mention the issue of
reciting the quran on behalf of the
deceased this is not something that is
part of the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
so let's break down this issue a little
bit
your melody
[Silence]
yes
is
[Silence]
he mentions that it was of his ways
that when he would visit the deceased
when he would be in a funeral
when someone would pass away that he
would be
very calm and tranquil
and he would be filled with
acceptance of the decree of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
and he would praise allah and he would
do is
allah belong we belong into allah we
are returning and he is associated
himself
from anyone who rips his clothing
during a during a hardship or
crisis or a person who raises his voice
in calling out to the dead or someone
who
raises his voice and screams during
crises
or a person who shaves his head during
crisis
now all of this is reported by imam
muslim
rahimahullah
we see this in movies a lot right
somebody dies or somebody gets upset and
he starts beating up the whole house and
breaking everything and then
you know he sits down and he thinks
about it and he gets it out of his
system
[Silence]
is
i
[Silence]
foreign